[Music]
I thought about going camping this
weekend that that's true I thought about
it just thought about it didn't do it
why because camping is something that
always looks great in like photos but
then the second I get out there I'm like
alright this is why we created
civilization and I can feel something
you're thinking right now even like I
like camping right now why is Bobcat
Goldthwait here and ownership and I get
it maybe camping it's for you and it
works for you but for me it always
sounds better than it is I picture it
perfectly
me sitting lazily by a creek bubblin
bubblin you know how Creek Zoo
bubble bubble I'm heating up some stew
garnished with dill that I foraged for
I'm just trying panning for gold just
with my hands killing it look haha knew
the river would provide but in reality
when I get there it's not like that at
all it's just being swaddling myself in
a mosquito net going do you mean there
are bears there's will then Oh run
what do you mean they're fast parents
are fast then I will climb a tree with
you had a third thing
they can climb trees why are we here
why are we here and how did we ever
defeat the bears there's how did we
divvy the Bears if you don't like
something I do it more the settlers of
this country did all this work is the
our man that they did all this work so
we would never have to deal with the
horrible reality of nature and it's
weird that we just go running back into
it tralala just for fun can you imagine
if you could tell a Pioneer if you could
go back in time and explain to a pioneer
as he schlepping around pitching a tent
rolling out a sleeping cloth on like dry
brittle dirt like hey in the future we
do this for fun for shit's and gigs [__]
some gigs we do that you'd be like yeah
you know who woulda liked that
Jeb you died 20 minutes ago from ant
bites in a case of the shit's and gigs
the only real activity when you're
camping in the real way is survival
that's it you go in you go deep try not
to die that's it there's no beds so
right off the bat you gotta you got to
remedy that got to find some level
ground to pitch your tent on
and maybe pony I'm turned on by flat
surfaces I don't know when the last time
you pitch a tent was but if you're doing
it for real like for you know shelter
you realize something real quick is that
level ground is not something that
occurs naturally we invented that [__]
that's what paved is oh but you and the
Hardy Boys wanted to sleep in the wild
so now you're gonna spend the whole
night unsure if you're on a hill or not
ever do that go to bed at 7:30 because
there's nothing to goldarn do I just
like I think I'm on a mild decline and
the woods are scary I'm scared I'm a
grown man I'll admit that scary spooky
scary don't like it and this is where we
choose to tell ghost stories you tell me
a ghost story in the middle of a sunny
Sunday brunch I still get the chills
surrounded by friends and bacon and
Bloody Mary's I'm like now we're in the
woods already scary and you're gonna
tell me the tale about the witch with
the rake for a hand I told you to do
your chores and there's real stuff in
the woods to be afraid of to like bugs
bugs
everywhere I mean there every I don't
mean there they are I mean that's where
they come from the Beatles move your
wings that wasn't on the card but
they're everywhere
that's why we paved everything to get
away from the horrific reality that bugs
are everywhere and we're just going back
and trying to blend in no stay separate
they don't do that to us you never see
them tried to assimilate see a scorpion
walking down Wall Street little
briefcase like if you can't beat them
join them
[Music]